hi everybody I am back from my brother's
wedding and I'm ready to crank out some
more videos um before any of you even
ask because I'm sure some of you are
curious no I didn't pull I'm a software
engineer don't assume such big things
out of me um additionally I'm not too
happy with how many subscribers I have
only like 37 in the past few days so uh
with that in mind you guys better start
subscribing quicker before I make some
toishan person on this app to be like I
work for Google you guys need to lead
code and that's how I got my job cuz uh
apparently everyone does that now and uh
just gets a ton of views doing it with
their with their day in their life
videos and sipping their coffee and
whatnot so you know before this channel
becomes into just like a a view whing
system let's let's get me some
subscribers so I can feel better about
myself okay with uh that pandering out
of the way let's get into uh
linearizability and ordering both are
super important for understanding how
consensus algor work and that'll
eventually segue us into understanding
how real life database systems work and
then we can talk about those okay okay
let's talk about linearizability and
ordering so what is linearizability well
if you've heard the term used before
linearizability is the same as strong
consistency more formally once an object
is written on any replica every single
subsequent read will get that updated
version of the object there are no stale
reads and hence that means that object
is going to be linearizable uh just a
quick note don't confuse linearizability
with serializability um you can still
have race conditions if you're trying to
make multiple rights at once in like a
transaction type of thing for example
you know if I have two rights and then
my friend has two rights they may be
interleaved in a way such that one of my
rights is going to win per se and be the
most recent one one of his is going to
win per se and be the most recent one
and then our database is kind of in like
a weird state but um you are still
reading technically the most upto-date
right per object so linearizability is
only a guarantee per object unlike
anything to do with serializability or
transactions when is linearizability
useful well it's really useful when you
want just one of something why because
it means that you're going to get the
most upto-date value so for example um
if we have a lock a distributed lock
that you know is fa tolerant in the
sense that it's replicated and there are
a bunch of replicas saying here's who's
currently holding the lock in the event
that one
crashes um what we want is that we
always want to get the most upto-date
value of which node is holding the lock
if this lock wasn't linearizable what
might happen is that um you know one
node might grab the lock release it and
then a second mode uh node might grab
the lock and then if I want to read
who's currently holding the lock uh a
stale replica might tell me that that
original node was still holding it and
that would obviously be a problem same
thing goes for uniqueness constraints in
a database um if all the replicas are
not you know in sync with one another at
the right time what might happen is um
you know I want to be golden shower
lover 100 and I write that to replica
one but then you write to replica 2 you
want the same username and my uh
username right has not been propagated
to replica 2 yet now we have a
conflict okay so what are the pros and
cons of linearizability well the pros
are that we get strong consistency every
single result that we get is up to date
we don't have to deal with stale reads
um we don't even have to you know think
about the possibility of them happening
the issue is that there's a huge
performance hit and uh once we see how
to implement linearizability which is
kind of strictly tied in with this idea
of consensus getting a bunch of nodes to
agree on something uh this is going to
make more sense but for now I'm just
going to kind of keep linearizability
and strong consistency as more of like a
conceptual thing and in subsequent
videos we'll go into how we actually
might Implement something like
linearizability
okay so linearizability and ordering so
if we're going to act as if there's only
one copy of the data right every single
replica has the same exact copy of the
data and any replica that makes a change
all those changes are instantly
propagated it means that there needs to
be a total order of operations on the
data it means that every single replica
the state on it can basically be
expressed as an order of you know rights
that's occurred and every single replica
has to have the same exact ordering um
additionally the fact that there's a
total order means that every single
operation is ordered it's not a partial
order ordering where some operations you
know can be concurrent or have um the
same location in an ordering they can't
be compared but rather total every
single operation comes before another
and after um so this order is going to
preserve causality um we know that if
one right is coming before another that
right is going to come before the other
in the total
order similarly if rights A and B are
concurrent it doesn't really matter
where A and B are with relation to each
other in the total order what matters
more so is that every single replica has
a and b in the same ordering relative to
one another um this is different than
something like a causal ordering where
you might actually just have a partial
order of the operation that preserves
causality so I'm going to show that off
in the next slide so first imagine we
have five rights um a b c d and e and so
a total order might order them something
like a b c then D then e but let's say A
and B were actually concurrent which if
you've watched my previous videos you
know the concurrent Rights happen when
two rights don't actually know about one
another you know there's no happens
before relationship they just happen at
the same time without actually knowing
that each other ever existed so imagine
A and B happened at the same time and d
and e happened at the same time a
partial order would say that A and B
were incomparable however maybe C knows
about both of them so we know that c is
greater than a and b and similarly if d
and e were concurrent we know that they
might have depended on C in order to
happen but they didn't know about each
other so the point is you can express
causality with just a partial ordering
um something like version vectors which
I've also covered in my multier
replication video um construct a partial
order in the fact that there are some
version vectors that can't be compared
they just tell you that two operations
are concurrent and you know in that case
you might create siblings or merge them
somehow but the point is that in a
partial order not all operations have to
be compared whereas in a total order
even if operations are concurrent you
still have to put them in that order
somehow
as you can see though in a partial
ordering what can happen is that say um
replica one does operation a then B and
then replica 2 does operation B then a
this might happen in something like um I
don't know a last right win scenario uh
what's going to happen is that these
replicas are going to be in an
inconsistent State and so we can't have
that because we said we want strong
consistency which means every replica
has to have the same exact
data okay so how do we create an
ordering well assuming we have something
like single leader replication with no
partitioning so all rights are going
through one node well we have a right
ahead log which is going to do this for
us however this gets a lot more
complicated in a scenario where there's
liter lless or multi- liter replication
so we can go into that right now um
there are two ways of basically doing
this one which is called Lamport
timestamps which I'll cover in the next
slide and another is version vectors
which work as well but they can also
take a lot of space if there are a bunch
of nodes okay so as far as Lamport
timestamps go they are basically a tuple
of two elements so there's this concept
of a counter and then there's a node ID
and using this counter node ID
combination we can actually get a total
ordering of the rights so let's go ahead
and do that let's imagine that the
counter starts at one for every single
client and database and then um each
database has a node ID so as you can see
we start off with two writes uh the top
client is going to write to the first
replica and the bottom client is going
to write to the second replica as you
can see their counters both start off
with one
okay now in the subsequent operations
the bottom replica is going to be
serving even more rights um so now the
counter is going to be incremented by
one every single time because the bottom
replica is getting new um right
operations so now these operations are 2
comma 2 and 3 comma 2 all makes sense so
far so now what's going to happen the
top client is now going to make yet
another right however it's writing to
the bottom replica so what's going to
happen is that instead of um that right
being numbered 2 comma 2 because um the
top client has only seen uh counter one
before the second that the top client
encounters um a higher counter than its
current one so in this case it sees
counter three on that second database
what it's going to do is actually uh
take its counter and take the maximum of
what it's seen so far and the maximum
counter on that replica and as a result
of that it now is going to increment
itself all the way to four now finally
since it's going to keep its counter at
four when it finally makes another right
to replica one we're going to write um
with counter five to replica one okay so
now to to kind of summarize this every
single client in replica keeps track of
the highest counter it's seen and if it
sees a Higher One it skips to that
number and then Additionally you might
say oh wait well look at those first two
operations how do we order them if they
have the same counter but different node
IDs all we do is just order the nodes
somehow so that we can have an arbitrary
tiebreaking order for the node IDs if
the counters are the same so our final
order is going to be 1 comma 1 1 comma 2
2 comma 2 3 comma 2 4 comma 2 and then 5
comma 1 we basically go by the counters
and if they're uh two operations with
the same counter we use the tiebreaking
node
order okay so what are the trade-offs of
Lamport timestamps especially when
compared diversion vectors which I
talked about in the past well I started
to touch on this but Lamport time stamps
take less space it's just Two element
tupal whereas version vectors are o of n
why are they o of n well it's n being
the number of replicas because every
single replica has to keep track of its
dependencies of um basically uh how up
to-date the other replicas are for
certain operation so in that sense since
you have a vector um with one element
per replica it takes linear space as
opposed to constant space and that's
obviously a problem when you're sending
things over the network an advantage of
version vectors on the other hand is
that they can actually Express
concurrent operations since they're a
partial ordering whereas Lamport time
stamps do not since they're a total
order by nature of the fact that Lamport
time stamps are a total order if we just
look at that Lamport ordering we don't
actually know if two operations have a
happens before relationship or they are
concurrent it's impossible to tell so
what happens when you have a total
ordering is that you can have data loss
um one operation is basically
arbitrarily kept over the uh another
using that kind of node ordering and
additionally that means that there's no
ability to do things like custom merging
or holding two rights as
siblings another issue with Lamport
timestamps is that they only provide us
with a total order retroactively so
imagine me and my friend both want the
username fupa sniffer 21 and we're
making rights to different replicas
concurrently even though the Lamport
timestamps will eventually get those two
replicas in a consistent State because
you know they'll eventually get all of
rights propagated to them and they'll
say oh you know we know the ordering of
each right and we can pick whether me or
my friend gets that username the fact
that they don't get that Lamport
timestamp in the moment means that both
me and my friend are going to think that
we had successful rights and then
eventually one of them is going to have
to be rolled back which is obviously
problematic okay so that leads us to
Total order broadcast I mentioned that
even though Lamport timestamps give us
an ordering of the operation it's not
happening in real time and as a result
of that it's not possible to actually go
ahead and use this as a way to um make
linearizable storage so as a result we
have this protocol called total order
broadcast which is basically saying this
if we have a bunch of you know reads and
writs all of the messages indicating a
read or a write operation need to be
delivered to every single node without
being lost so no Dro messages and
additionally the messages need to be
delivered in the same order to every
single node and like I mentioned that's
just called total order broadcast I
haven't said how this would be
implemented yet but um you know this
allows us to make linearizable storage
and I'll Express how right now so as far
as rights go you just go ahead and add
them in the log and obviously each right
has to be sent to every single replica
in the moment they have to be performed
in the same order which is kind of why
it's important that there are no dropped
messages and they're sent in the same
order um and so for example you know how
does this work for a uniqueness
constraint well you know first the
database would perform the right for the
first username because it gets them in
the correct order and then the database
could see that any subsequent rights to
a username are going to be violating
that uniqueness constraint as far as
reads go we want to make sure that we're
actually getting strong consistency and
not eventual consistency the total order
broadcast basically said that all the
messages will be sent to every single
replica in the right order and not be
dropped however I never said anything
about when they would get there so for a
read in particular if you're making a
read from a replica you can't just go
ahead and instantly read it there second
there's a read request instead we need
to also add the read to this log of or
uh operations that total order broadcast
is creating and only once that replica
gets to the read in the in the log can
it actually perform this read and make
sure that everything is going to be up
to
date okay so now let's quickly talk
about consensus um even though total
order broadcast can be used to create
linearizable storage and also I didn't
really touch on this but linearizable
storage can easily be used to create
total order broadcast because you know
imagine we had linearizable storage and
then um I used basically like an atomic
counter and so that counter would be
able to order every single operation um
on the database so we could easily do it
that way we haven't actually said how to
create either of these two things well
as it turns out both of these problems
are reducible to the consensus problem
the consensus problem being how can we
get a bunch of nodes with unrel viable
networks and nodes that might crash to
generally agree on something and make
sure to um you know come to a consistent
state so uh in future videos I'll
discuss two or three ways of actually
achieving consensus amongst nodes and
we'll see that they're definitely um you
know pros and cons amongst using
consensus in your application where the
biggest hit is definitely performance
but sometimes you still need to be using
it so in summary uh as far as
linearizability goes we're basically
just acting as if there's one copy of
the data amongst all the replicas known
as strong consistency um as far as
ordering goes if there's no partitions
and you can deal with a single leader
for all of your rights um it's really
easy to achieve something like total
order broadcast however um if you're
using a multileader or leader lless
configuration you probably have to go
ahead and use Lamport timestamps even
still Lamport timestamps don't actually
solve our issue of creating linearizable
or strongly consistent storage because
they only order those operations
retroactively uh the messages aren't
delivered in order to every single node
but rather we can just order them after
the fact which is not sufficient for
total order broadcast and then finally
even though total order broadcast and
linearizability are not the same because
total order broadcast doesn't actually
say when those messages are going to be
delivered you can use total order
broadcast to achieve linearizability and
you can use linearizability to achieve
total order
broadcast and then finally if you can
avoid having to deal with strong
consistency you probably just should
often times it's enough to have um
causally consistent data which is
basically saying if a happens before B
you should never be able to read b in a
database unless you also be able to read
a um so I know that this video has been
really theoretical for the most part and
you know there's not too much um like
actual content that you need to know
other than the Lamport timestamp stuff I
consider this like a pretty solid primer
for for just like consensus in general
because it's basically saying that if
you really ever want to be achieving um
strong consistency all the replicas have
to go ahead and be receiving all of the
operations in the same order more or
less at the same time and to do so this
is a consensus problem so we'll get into
how we can achieve consensus in the next
few videos and again this is still
pretty theoretical and complicated stuff
but it's important to know how to do um
whether that's in a system designed
interview or also possibly even just in
your actual work